[Music]
49 years ago this month the allman
brothers band released their live album
at fillmore east it was recorded here in
new york and propelled the almonds to
stardom
putting southern rock on the map the
allman brothers were the first act on
capricorn records the label had a
historic run and became known
as the birthplace of southern rock but
later was mostly forgotten
that is until this year when capricorn
reopened for business
[Music]
all of us that worked here and had so
many wonderful times
we feared that it'd just be demolished
inside mercer music at capricorn in
macon georgia
a newly renovated recording studio has
been resurrected
from the dustbin of music history this
is the room
the room wow you know it just floods
back memories
it's where a 20 year old chuck lavelle
would come to work in 1972
as a new member of the allman brothers
band joining the likes of greg allman
butch trucks and dickie bets we would
set up the whole band
we could all see each other and that was
important why well you know to get the
feeling the emotion and you know
watching greg sing
and watching dicky play that guitar am i
allowed to ask you to
play a little show something yeah all
right here we go
some of southern rock's most enduring
hits were made in this room
the product of all night jam sessions
where lavell says they would
literally pick a key and go
so amazing so a little taste of it there
yeah
lavell can still recall the first time
betts strummed the beginnings of the
song jessica
principal melody is
but then you had
and then you had the other parts or you
[Music]
get
the seven and a half minute instrumental
was recorded for the 1973 album brothers
and sisters
[Music]
along with the almonds anthem rambling
man
[Music]
the story of capricorn records is one of
revivals
the lesser known in a constellation of
recording studios in the south
like sun studios in memphis and fame in
muscle shoals alabama
capricorn was based in macon a town 80
miles southeast of atlanta
that happens to be the hometown of
little richard
and otis redding otis was managed by
phil walden who was the owner of
capricorn records and who
built this for otis for him to record
reading would die tragically in a 1967
plane crash
walden was looking for a new act to
manage when he heard dwayne allman's
session work with the likes of aretha
franklin
and wilson pickett and he sought out
dwayne and he said i want to manage you
i don't care what kind of band you put
together it doesn't matter whatever you
want to do
and so dwayne put together the allman
brothers band
dwayne allman would gather an eclectic
ensemble that included
redding's drummer jmo their combination
of
country gospel r b and motown would
blend into the emerging
new sound of southern rock when
capricorn started and the allman
brothers did their first record it
really didn't sell that well
second record really didn't sell that
well so all of us that were involved
here making music
you know we were determined let's keep
that kettle boiling you know let's just
keep at it keep at it keep attic and
then
it was the live at fillmore east record
that really broke for the almond
brothers
just three months later dwayne allman
died
in a motorcycle accident
but the band would regroup making
capricorn the epicenter of southern rock
everyone from joe cocker to leonard
skinnard would record here
[Music]
now i feel like i'm going into an old
record store
basically that story is told in the new
museum at capricorn
a project that took archivist jared
wright nearly a decade to curate
it begins with its roots in seoul people
like otis redding sam and dave
to groups like the marshall tucker band
known for hits like
can't you see
there's even some presidential politics
jimmy carter would visit the studio
before launching his 1976 campaign
piracy and duping of tapes was a really
big problem
when carter was governor phil walden
worked with him to pass that anti-piracy
bill
that protected artists rights carter
credits the label's key financial
support through benefit concerts with
keeping his candidacy alive
and not just the almonds the marshall
tucker band but the whole capricorn
label was kind of behind carter and
helping him run for president
but all this rich history nearly
disappeared
capricorn struggled through the 1980s
the building abandoned in disrepair
was owned by nearby mercer university
there were holes in the floor
see through to the basement the floor
behind us had completely collapsed
the ceiling was starting to come in
and i thought my what a dump
but and then i walked into the studio
yeah
and sort of miraculously it was
the one space that had been perfectly
preserved
mercer president william underwood was
left with a dilemma
i knew that i couldn't tear this
building down
because of you know the great history
here and i also couldn't afford to fix
it
which is a big problem the building
would change hands numerous times
until a developer finally gifted it back
to the university
a combination of fundraising and tax
breaks financed a more than
four million dollar renovation the new
capricorn
open to the public in january its two
studios
available to commercial artists
recording albums along with an incubator
space for young musicians
to practice and collaborate why was it
so important to keep
the capricorn sound studios and build
from there
i viewed the history as a way to inspire
the future
and maybe the next otis reading will
come out of that incubator the studio is
sort of
a living testament to the fact that it
can happen here and it has happened here
when you saw that capricorn records was
going to be reborn in a sense
what did you think hallelujah
lavelle is still nostalgic about the
past
i wish i had taken more piano lessons
but he revels
in the here and now it was a magical
magical time during those years
when you're back here do you feel some
of that magic again i do
i do feel the magic it's here it's never
gone away
it just went to sleep for a while
i shouldn't point out we obviously shot
that pre covered pretty cool with the
closest
so chuck lavelle was just about to leave
with the rolling stones because he's
been touring with them since the early
80s he's their sort of de facto musical
director
but he's right there's something you
could feel there i can't describe it but
there was something there with that
history that was so rich you can see it
just on the screen yeah then i wanted to
learn piano all over too right like i
feel like i'm getting elected
going into the music awesome it was
really really really
great um and fun to sort of reminisce
about some of those songs anybody who
loves albums that space of listening to
albums was truly
amazing to have post covert a good place
to visit for
forever yeah postcode